hey everybody welcome to another episode
of riffing with Griffin I want to thank
everybody for watching this is gonna be
a special on the road episode of riffing
with Griffin I was out in Tempe at the
improv in Arizona and I got mr. Frank
Caliendo to come on the podcast he said
I could film it at his studio I didn't
know that he just built the studio and
it wasn't up to par yet he didn't have
lights
he had these crazy cameras and then I
look out in his backyard cuz I'm
thinking all right he's got this
ginormous dumbass Hollywood pool out
there I mean the pool is dumb it is big
dumb and you know he spent all his money
on that but now all of a sudden he got
all the good cameras the moment I left
and then he sent me this video Eric just
having a great morning enjoying my
incredibly expensive pool at the beach
entry over there Island behind me it's
gonna be a pretty big island to get seen
behind my head and there's the rock
formation there's a slide going through
that think about adding another slide in
there maybe another waterfall raise the
cliffs a little bit for some cliff
diving god I just love that rock
formation I you know that's the thing
about pools is you just want to be
state-of-the-art with them all the time
keep adding to them and just have them
be the best possibly at the forefront of
technology as far as pools go anyway
thanks for doing the show in here I'm
sure everything worked out great no
issues at all okay I gotta get back I
got some architecture to deal with in
terms of that rock formation this guy is
I'm coming to swim Frank but everybody
enjoyed this episode of riffing with
Griffin and once again thanks for
watching hit it all right ladies and
gentlemen
I know this looks weird but welcome to
your favorite podcast you know the name
and I'm here on the road in Arizona with
the very funny is the legend the living
legend himself mr. Frank Caliendo
now I don't have my singing bag because
I'm normally on here
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the words right now you got it I did it
backwards I like to take my owns I'll
just take what you already had a little
style put some stank on it yeah put some
stank out anyways dude thanks for having
me thanks for hosting my podcast well
you know your host I guess I'm hosting
the venue your host air you're hosting
the venue for the UM so you know this is
great like we you know we don't know
each other you know what I mean and um
you know that before the last couple
days right right exactly but like I've
known about you I've heard about you
I've seen you I'm a fan you know you
you've done you've been doing this for
such a long time and but like are you
still enchanted with the comedy business
you know what I've become more I become
Rhian chanted reinter that's actually
what it is I had gotten stuck doing so
much of it for people who don't know me
which is anybody under 35 no for unless
you have a dad that watch and I'm 45
it's this weird phase where I've just I
was stuck doing the same kind of thing
the thing people know me the most for is
the John Madden impression over the
years it was just that and everywhere I
go I never realized why when somebody
would go on a talk show or something I
say I don't want to do the thing I'm
known for all the time cuz Leno would
bring me do some John Madden do some
John man and then everybody's like oh
that's all he does and then you start to
get pigeonholed and I was making so much
money I like you like
pigeonhole me all the way to the bank
that's a pigeon abyss I'm fine with she
started a production company called
pigeon holes I was right there and
that's it's for me it's interesting
because it was not just impressions and
like it was sports impressions so they
put you in a category of sports and
impressions and then like the rest of
Hollywood looks at you it was like oh
you do two things we don't care for so
do things we can't put on TV yes unless
it's on with sporting events which we
why am I talking like it doesn't fit
genre no you are incredibly rich person
and this is your studio this is very
nice oh yeah you know and as I just
built this with change so loose change
but you know what you know what we
started wrong okay you right people
don't know I know but people that my
listeners especially the young ones not
they're not gonna know you know a lot of
my listeners like Bobby Lee fans you
know what I mean yeah here's the thing I
was on MADtv with my body you have to
play him and his brother I was put a
crushed both of them and if he wants to
refute that I heard youhere force to lay
in my garage you've heard here first
Bobby was crushed by Frank and there was
no ping-pong there was a period of time
where it was pretty close but then I
took some lessons and then she now
that's that's you want to get better
golf you go to a golf pro you learned
the game I played with some Olympians oh
yeah that's how much you wanted to beat
Bobby no no I could you had some ping
pong Olympians flown in from China and
you know I went to China now and people
don't realize that there is a reality of
that in the Asian countries and this is
a really high level table tennis by the
way you go is it ping-pong or table 10
which one ping-pong ping-pong is
actually a name brand it's a q-tip or
Kleenex
Oh table tennis is the actual game I
seen then you know I did not know that
so in China and some of the other agent
like Korea and Korea's actually there's
two different curries but the Koreans
which I'm guessing probably the South
Koreans I'm saying you really wanted to
be Bobby if you went to North Korea
what about doing that as me at the time
george w bush and him can kim jong ill
at the time playing ping-pong for like
by ping-pong diplomacy which was
actually a thing that happened i think
during the Nixon administration
ping-pong but yeah there's a real Google
it there's an older thing but uh Bobby
and I great friends until recently and
Bobby we my family will all go out to
see Bobby cover the kids eyes when he
starts to take the clothes off yeah just
be glad I don't do that because jungle
so outrageous you're Italian you were
here we go yeah back is a mess yeah my
back is worse than most people so it's
just uh yeah played ping-pong table
tennis with Bobby a lot his brother was
there sometimes but I've even improved a
lot since then so that's a that's a
channel the challenge has been put out
yeah let's do it somebody goes there's
some kind YouTube channel or something
has like celebrities playing ping-pong
that's a new thing to doing it now they
just started something new right now one
of the one of the guys from workaholics
to director Kyle nuna check I think he's
a part of that ok I think I think
they're doing it yeah the only guy that
I that could beat me and it would depend
it was because of the kind of paddle he
plays with is uh things like so
ping-pong nerdy right oh no no cuz it's
a type of paddle he plays well yeah cuz
he plays with these plays with these
other types of pips that are pips out
that changes the spin of the ball or
it's not regulation
no it's regulation it's just a different
style of playing and you have to get
used to it like it's in your mind you
have to anticipate that the balls gonna
when a ball hits a sticky service it
reverses and goes the opposite way when
it hits this surface it continues the
same spin so if I go top spin to your
top spin and you have the same kind of
paddle it's just fast back and forth but
if you hit it to the other kind of
paddle I hit it with topspin it comes
back reverse and your brain has to
figure that then people have two
different sides
that's why we've lost every V I know I
ping pong episode ping pong Judah
Friedlander let's get something else you
should skip forward to this point Donald
Trump ping pong is a tremendous game
but I don't like any of the people
playing it all right so this is great so
this is what actually I'm glad you just
did that cuz this is with you but you're
you're known for is you do a lot of
great impression from end tremendous
impression renders incredible
impressions probably the number one
impressionist on this show right now and
I went down loads going through they
could do a pretty good oh you're doing
fantastic that was almost Nixon though
yeah I'm terrible with that I just do I
could do like you did a lot of great
characters yeah that's that's a
different but you actor you have it's a
definitely dead-on skill so you've done
impressions for a long time then you
started doing a lot of sports
impressions and that's what became
famous for you on Fox a Sunday Fox NFL
Sunday
well Sunday the ESPN doing some other
stuff there yeah so you kind of went
into that groove and you were just out
on the road doing all that after your
MADtv years so that that gets everybody
caught up on that so but I can tell from
talking to you that like so once you got
into that Lane of being an impressionist
and making a lot of money doing that
yeah that's when you became pigeon-holed
into that Johnny because I would just do
it all the time and it was easier I mean
that's a big part of it is it was I
think there's a there's a huge element
of laziness and being complacency so
that's the word right for some reason
didn't feel like a word but I think it's
not will make it one but it was this
whole thing of that was the easiest
thing for me to do so if I call up a
radio station to promote a show I could
easily just go into all the characters
right away I didn't want to tell stories
I would just start talking as the
characters people would ask for the
characters and they would talk to the
characters and they wouldn't even talk
to me and it would end up selling a
bunch of tickets and stuff like that but
at the same time people weren't learning
about me that's one of the thing I love
about podcasts and I've learned about
podcasts is that people get an emotional
attachment to you here and they learn
about you and they they start to
understand where you're coming from them
I must i'ma show an act that people come
to see right they don't necessarily come
after watching you I would come to see
what's your take on something actually
I'm interested to know what your takes
are because I I found you very
intelligent and tell
I found you to be curious and fun
jovial but also pointed and you made a
lot of great points I I'm watching that
gun okay I get it I understand now okay
now now you're saying this now so I feel
like there came up first of all you
can't downplay the level of talent it
takes to do what you do but because it's
easy for you you kind of like push it
off to the side okay but it's the easy
thing but it's not easy okay everybody
can't do magic is right right right but
what happens everybody can stand around
and watch it when a magician goes on and
does magic you're like do another trick
that's what impressions do another trick
now every once in a while there's a
David Copperfield and you're like I want
to see David Copperfield it's not
necessarily I want to see the magic of
David I went to see David Copperfield I
want to be if I'm doing impressions and
part of my act I want to be the David
Copperfield impression impressions
that's more of what it is as opposed to
being hey you're the guy who does the
John Madden how did you get now as this
was going on and you know the fame and
fortune was happening and did at what
point did you go like oh my god like
this is this is just all I'm gonna be is
that the point that you've been at right
now I'm thinking like I want to do more
I want to do I didn't really want to do
more for a while because I kids once I
had kids that became my priority I'm
having trouble with certain words
multisyllabic words I already said old
school Tom broke up all right second
turn anything to the person from 40
years ago so uh that's part of the
problem too right you know yeah because
I guess right now people are like who's
John Madden right yeah that's why they
don't they only know Madden is a video
game he's not even a person he it's not
even real it's it's I start it that's
why I started watching like more of
things like Avengers my daughter got
into Avengers started doing a Robert
Downey junior okay do me a favor enjoy
me because it may not be here that long
all right he's actually turned I talk
about this in my act a little bit it's
one of the points I make he's actually
turned into the Tony Stark guy all the
time have you seen he's like we're going
to change the world yeah yeah
and make it better I am Iron Man like
you're not Iron Man he started some
foundation to his come dark stark
industries when you've made something
but again for him right he's he actually
got Frank Caliendo because he was like
I've been doing Tony Stark now for
eleven years I've made so much money as
Tony Stark he was the highest-paid actor
for like five years in a row every time
an Avengers movie comes out he's the
highest-paid actor and then he was like
well this is so I took I went to a Comic
Con in Seattle and I know I know some of
them to some of the people from the
Comic Cons and this is ace Con in
particular the really great one with the
high level people and it's on my
Instagram and I tell people this is my
daughters Avengers themed birthday party
and it's her with Josh Brolin Zoe
Saldana Don Cheadle Chris Evans and
Jeremy Renner and I tell people that's
my Avengers themed birthday party like
that's the actual Avengers I'm like I
know but one of the things it was
interesting because trying to work on
some of these newer impressions like the
first one I met was Tom Hiddleston who
plays Loki and he does a Jeff Goldblum
impression so he started doing the Jeff
Goldblum's together very very good it
was funny of the perspective because he
was like then yes and I am do
impressions of people I'm in movies with
and I'm like oh I do impressions of
people I've seen in the movies like I'm
out of that level he was super nice and
is great but then so we end up I have
this video footage of Josh Brolin and
it's of him in a junket where reporters
asking about if he knows of me this is
when he did the movie W and he talks
about he's like yeah I Frank Caliendo
he calls me Frank Kelly in tow by the
way I wouldn't see ya Frank Caliendo
yeah which I'm changing my name for I
love when people say they think they say
they know you they like if I get called
Erik Griffith it's I've been happens all
the test
so he says Frank Caliendo he was one of
the reasons Oliver and I Oliver Stone
Oliver and I wha
thats what we based the comedic lee up
the parts of the movie
oh so I went and I met him we went to go
into the
to take pictures because I didn't have
full access at this one like I did with
the Tom Hiddleston one so we went to to
meet him any I don't usually take the
pictures with people at these Comic Cons
because I'm like it feels weird it's
like if I'm what I'm gonna do put on
Instagram and wipe out the background
and make it seem like we're just hanging
out yeah like I can't do that so I don't
really take the picture but with Josh
Brolin I went to take the picture
because one of the guys from Ace Khan's
like you gotta take the picture with him
I go take take a picture and I'm like
hey Frank Caliendo and he looks at me
like hey doing why do I know this guy
does this you know is this one of my
cousins or something like that and he
didn't say anything but it was this look
and we took the picture the look on his
face is why what I know why and my wife
Michelle she's just on the side it's
like he's completely not realized she's
there I didn't put this up obviously
because it's just kind of been off it's
kind of awkward but kind of awesome so
later I talked to my agent and I said
because I have the same agents and I
said hey can you actually get me to meet
him so I can spend some time I went and
talked to me we Chris Evans is there at
the same time and he said oh my gosh
I couldn't believe he's like I didn't
realize it was you or whatever it was
and Chris Evans like what he's like I
did that movie it was all based on what
he does talking about me and Kristin was
like what movie and I'm like oh he's
like what role I'm like Thanos and so
which was a completely but he's like and
then Chris Evans who's be great so who
is I screwed up the story telling him
but Chris Evans like wait a second who
are you and I was like Frank Kelly he
goes oh my god like he went crazy cuz
he's a New England Patriots fan he
starts telling me all the stuff I do and
my daughter is like Captain America
knows you this is the greatest day of my
life
yeah and that's funny cuz I'm telling
him it's so funny to me I'm like well
you don't understand what it's like to
be pigeonholed in a role cap yeah for 11
years yeah yeah at least yours at least
his as Captain America was making like
if I made a lot of money his was
trumping that by quite a bit but then
later we actually ran into Chris Evans a
little bit later he saw me came over and
talked to me a little bit more of my
daughter's like this day just got better
I'm like why is that he she goes he
didn't
have to talk to you this time he wanted
to talk to you
it's thing that she was aware of oh
she's told like she's like she can quote
every Avengers movie all kinds of stuff
she's totally and she broke her elbow a
year a year ago on her birthday and then
this was on her birthday that she met
all these Avengers and so Chris Evans
and Josh Brolin are getting totally into
this about her talking about her elbow
and she's like yeah I hadn't watched a
Marvel movie ever really and then I got
into it a year ago and Chris I was like
wait a second you've only been watching
this a year and you know like holy yeah
and he was just it was so funny because
he was the real Chris Evans I mean you
could see him on the on the on the panel
he just he doesn't have much of a much
of a sensor button he's just like it's
wearing a completely all rise very funny
just to watch him in real life because
he's not Captain America's really great
truly authentic and same with Josh
Brolin these are mega stars now in this
moment then is that like because you're
thinking to yourself they act they know
your work but they can't people don't
put it together that this guy Rika's ice
work that they love they don't expect me
to be I'm five six and when I people
think that I'm gonna be this big guy
because of all the characters I played
them or they think I'm gonna be Will
Sasso who people get me and Will Sasso
confused cuz we're both fat guys on
MADtv at one point yeah and they'll get
me Confed white guys yeah Artie Lange I
mean it's already Lange when I went on
Stern years ago Artie made I'd only been
on Stern once I went in Stern and I was
kind of scared about it I was doing in
our macdonald impression and that he
liked that but Artie who's great friends
with norm was just going cry and talking
me up and Stern loved it it was just one
of those moments in my life I was like
this is really cool like Stern's like
and so Stern I don't do a great Howard
Stern impression he's like so do you
were you cheating on your wife he's like
yeah you don't you're a nice guy he went
on oh my god what are you
I just do it short enough and yeah I
start there we go okay it's just quick
complete sentence it might be messed up
yeah I don't I don't use punctuation
yeah
I just try to get out of it and mumble
through it a little bit and it's just
got to be good and that's something with
that's how I like to use the impressions
now what did you start doing impressions
I probably started in like middle school
oh this has been your thing from Y an
inch I didn't really know I didn't like
everybody else that I would watch and
live in color but that's when I was in
middle school high school is uh you know
Damon Wayans characters going you know
that kind of stuff doing the fire
marshal built those types of things and
then I learned that I don't like doing
the characters that people would do on
other shows I would try to talk like the
actual person right which is different
yeah like somebody I'm gonna do a Tom
Hanks impression they go laughs it's
like a box
no that's Forrest Gump that's not the
impression if I was gonna do a Damon
Wayans it would be more like debt you
know this kind of thing I don't do a
great Damon ways but if that's the
that's the way to get to it or a Billy
Crystal nobody even knows who it is of
course you can you know maybe you could
figure it out so you do those those
weirder ones and the weird ones like the
Tom Hiddleston I was and doing and
that's just him talking and normally so
it you do that you find something weird
about like I found this is more visual
thing so more people watching it like
with a thing that I'm trying to work on
for this show is like Tony Stark
Robert Downey jr. talking to Bruce
Banner Hey Bruce doing that thing where
you scrunch up your face and are a
little confused I don't if you're
talking about Tony like every time it's
that that's that's the relationship and
that's the fun thing about it so finding
those things and just moving on from
them I do a little bit mag now it talks
even a little bit of pitch in a
pigeonholing I'm trying to find the
threads that I'll put this to put this
two phone together
chris hemsworth we know him Thor right
and we know him from that Loki my
brother that whole thing yeah he's cast
as Hulk Hogan and you think about that
audition the first time he goes in Chris
can you come in
sure no problem could you do a little
while he'll come and the voice first no
problem let me tell you something
brother
and this is something we talked about
back on my podcast is that before Alan
Frank tried to be serious
was that there's the reaction like I can
do the voice but it's the reaction of me
playing the other part through reacting
to the cut of the voice that's actually
the funny part that makes the whole bit
work Zack yes so there's that and that's
a that's one thing that like other
comedians one of the things I've gotten
I'd say lucky on comedians who are
monologist and great storytellers they
usually liked me because I had an act
and the act was written to not just hey
here's the impression here is a story a
set up a reason for the Emperor's this
character in this situation and not just
that an observation on the person so
what's your take and acting you you know
we talked about acting as well and one
of the things about acting is you talked
about drama and how you have to have the
backstory yeah I actually tried to like
take a person like Al Pacino
so Al Pacino for me my take on him is
he's amazed by everything and acting
you're curious right Al Pacino was one
of the greatest actors of all time
arguably the greatest actor of all time
to some people so he's super curious so
he's amazed by everything even a simple
light turning on the light switch I was
like wait a second you mean
you turn you flip a switch over there
and a light goes on over there wow this
is sorcery and that's that's what the
take is and then the take there are
people that do better impressions than
me
you want YouTube most of the people
doing the stuff they just do a line from
a movie and move on but you can't do a
sketch or you can't do a comedic bit
based on that because what's the take on
the person so but that was the way that
was done for so long those like you
would see comics I'd come in from like
you know the mid 90s early 2000s it was
like there's some impression and people
do an impression and that's what you
just said is how it would be done even I
think it was older than that and that's
why it died out because people weren't
taking Dana Carvey did it and Jim Carrey
did it and took a take with the people
and cart
more but what happened was impressions
did not evolve the same way asthma
Knology and those type of and
storytelling did they it stayed
vaudevillian it stayed very old-school
like okay and now what if Jack Nicholson
was eating a banana and you're going is
there reason I don't get it where is
this coming from but what I try to do is
try and make them like characters and
set them up as people and that's what
I'm trying to do in the act now or even
in real life is take things you do a
great job of this is you take a person
you you let somebody know how what the
point of view is of the person you
become the person the problem for me is
they're waiting for it to be an
impression sometimes gotcha so it's
almost like I go up and if I don't talk
about impressions right away even the
fact that I'm trying to get away and do
something different with them it's like
they're waiting for the impressions
they're like what's what's again it's
like Jeff Dunham showing up without the
puppets it's character and I can tell
this is like something that's you're at
a crossroads right now yeah and I've
been there about a year realizing after
I started learning about acting I
started working with an acting coach I
was like geez there's just so much I
never wanted to be an actor I didn't
yeah I didn't know all I ever really
wanted to be Eric and you know this is
serious cuz they used your name in it
all I wanted to be was a guest on talk
shows real it's really that was my goal
was to be the guy sitting next to a Jay
Leno just talking it's just killing it
on the couch yeah just being on the
couch I mean I didn't want to do
stand-up on a lot of I I held off my
first Tonight Show they asked me you
want to be on tonight's show I was like
yeah they're like well stand up for five
minutes I'm like I'll wait till you want
me on the couch and then they eventually
wanted me on the couch and that to me
was I just went because it's really the
same kind of thing is just telling
stories but I always wanted to be that
because when I was on stage when I was
you know doing stand-up it just was a
puppet show and I don't want to be I
don't mind the puppets being part of the
show but I don't want them to be the
whole show and then so I feel you have
some contempt for that is it contempt no
it's just because I want to I mean yeah
okay it's yes it's I just want to grow
and be more than that I just it's not
that I've
prot I it's not a hatred mm-hmm but
listen it's more of hey just give me a
chance to do what else other things I
can do don't shut me out don't turn me
off don't not listen to me because
you're only waiting for this
you know how but it can we ask you how
do you know that people are a list
wouldn't listen cuz they tell you
they're like all that I'm like what do
you think of this I didn't even know you
did that like I just did it in the show
what do you mean I talked about my son
oh you have a son alright so you feel so
then you feel like the the impress we'll
see you know this reminds me of like
you're doing a show and then like
there's somebody in the crowd some
heckler does something and then like I
messed with this heckler right mm-hmm
then after the show someone comes on it
goes oh man my favorite part of the show
is when you were messing with that guy
in the crowd right I hate all this
material I've worked on a few years I've
cultivated this act and the thing you
remember the most is that it's very
frustrating so I feel like you feel like
that about the impression Airy similar
yeah I think it's because there's an art
to both right not every comedian can
shut down a heckler yeah not every
comedian could do an impression or a
character so there's a there's an
element to it but yeah it's like I've
worked on all this stuff she said please
pay it's acknowledge that it's there uh
that's all that's all I really want out
of it it's I know the impressions are
what it's always gonna be the probably
the biggest thing for me but even when I
go on friends shows like people have had
me on shows about Hot in Cleveland
Sullivan & Son it's good friend of mine
Steve Byrne glowstick um
brilliant guy very funny you know they
rewrite the part when you get there the
writers are like okay yeah but we want
to utilize all the impressions that I
never get to be against like here's a
guy that so your your character on the
show that does impression right so now
I'm once again the one-dimensional guy
that doesn't have a chance to develop
and be seen and and go that next very
skilled dimension though by the way you
just I know that you're it's easy for
you and you've been doing it so long
that you just kind of like you know you
kind of put off to the side of being
like a but it's still yeah I mean I
don't I don't have any hatred for it I
know it's not you just want more you
want to evolve yeah I just want to be
more it's any kind of I never used to
understand Adam Sandler
Jim Carrey or any comedian who wanted to
do a dramatic role cuz I'm like you're
at the top of the world in this game why
would you want to be something else
because you just feel like you can be
more you just feel like hey you've
gotten the chance to do dramatic roles
yeah comedic roles do stand-up comedy
when you can do different things you
just start to feel wow I'm pretty
well-rounded in this business and
there's a great feeling for that yes
because like the grass is always greener
on the other side you know cuz it's like
the people I feel like the most
successful comics in the last 10 20
years are ones that have sort of
specialty or they know their crowd you
know it's like it's like you know it's
like the the blue-collar guys you know
they have a they know who they're
they're talking to they have this
character they do this thing and it's
like super successful you know even Jeff
Dunham Jeff Dunham we talked about you
know he he had his thing you know even
if it was something that maybe he was
sick of doing or if people only looked
at him like that it was that it was
super successful and it's like you know
it's like a jack of all trades master of
none
is that better or worse I don't know
yeah I mean if you're if you could if
you believed you could be really good at
something else and I think I'm getting
to that point do I think I'd be a great
actor too let's say five years ago I I
was a terrible actor but I learned about
acting and I spent the time to learn
just give me the chance to try and act a
little bit as opposed to oh you're that
impression guy well what it's gonna be
then is that you're gonna be in a part
and people are not even gonna associate
it that's what's gonna happen that's
what you really want I guess yeah
they're gonna bit is that Frank Killian
yeah yeah yeah I've got you know I've
got your glasses and a mustache like I
steal your look like The Drew Carey
Brian Haley ever hear that they had the
similar-looking drew cares hey guys got
my look man about yeah yeah how come you
never like like I'm I always thought
that I would see you like you would be
on like we look like wheel of fortune or
or like oh you'd be the neck you'd be on
family feud you know or something like
that
Hosting yeah holding it oh I felt like
just a contestant no no got ya I've
really demoted you know I would be
like I could totally have seen you being
like the Family Feud host uh you know
what I was so rigid I don't I had a lot
of chances to host early on I didn't
feel like I do a good job and now after
working on the podcast doing more
podcast and getting out there and just
talking when I would get on stage I
would want laughs like boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom and you know as a
good the best comedians don't really
have that the best comedians just have
hold of the audience and then take them
with and that you laugh when they want
you want you to laugh yeah and that you
listen at the other time so you judged
yourself a lot on that standard yeah I
just was so it was I just like getting
the laughs so so much because I felt
like that's what I needed to do is laugh
count but there's a reality as people
never get to know you when it's just all
the voices in the laughs count and I
feel like this is a theme that you have
right now that this is very important
for you for people to get to know Frank
Caliendo the man the person yeah and
those talents I feel like this is
something that you're really striving
for yeah absolutely but again I couldn't
have done it a few years ago I would I
wouldn't have all this time where we
were just talking I'd be like do I need
to do another voice right right right I
almost thinking about that how can I
work the next voice and so people know
it's me feeling that I had to or they
were tuning em and what I found is that
honesty and vulnerability are two things
that people if they kind of know about
you and you're on a platform like this
where your viewers your listeners are
tuning in and they trust your judgment
on a guest you're having on because at
the beginning you you probably have not
you necessarily specifically but anybody
starts out they like I'll take any guess
I can get and then as it goes on you're
like I really I know where my audience
is going I want to I want people that I
think my audience is gonna like and then
if they have to have a trust for that
right and here's a trust that and then
your audience trust you and that's how
it really grows well I started off by
doing like solo episodes just talk about
whatever was going on that week and I
would give a take on those things mm-hmm
but then it was like you know I also
wanted to have gasps you know I know a
lot of great people and I was like I
want to talk to like all the guys from
workaholics I'm gonna talk to some guys
deine appears I want to talk to other
comics right you know so there's but
there's fun you can even talk about some
of the same things you talked about when
you do a solo episode you bounce it off
of somebody else and it gives a
different perspective now you actually
have a new perspective or you have a
change or you have your audience is with
you and they're learning something new
that's the great thing about guess is
something new comes of it a new
perspective a new way of learning and
that's where I'm at I think I just used
to just want to present and shoot
everything out and just throw it out at
everybody and throw it won't see what's
stuck but you also want to be great at
it right you're you seem to be like very
meticulous about like you wanted the act
to be and then so you knew you were
great at that so you didn't necessarily
want to step out and take chances and
absolutely scared to death scared scared
hugely scared to take that time to take
a moment pause jaemor years ago said to
me he's like you're going too fast you
got to slow down
I'd even understand what that meant I
was just I was like yeah but I'm doing
great he's like yeah you're killing but
you're just spewing so much stuff out
people don't have a time to take a
breath and I'm like yeah why do they
need to breathe laughing yeah I'm busy
destroying worlds but then you start to
realize hey I can say something I'd love
to get a point across
I took a I took it not in your standup
are you saying that she was like that
stuff yeah yes the podcasts are helping
me do that do it yeah even talking you I
took this class I went the University of
wisconsin-milwaukee this is 20 years ago
and maybe a little bit more now and
there was a teacher and the only reason
I point this out is because she made a
point of it at this time it was this was
pretty out there I guess out there I
don't know what to say but more judgment
on this person she she was a lesbian
and she it was a big part of her point
you know where she was coming from her
world yeah in shades that everybody know
yeah it was called stand-up comedy and
the other and the other is who the joke
is making fun of and it's
you know laughing are we laughing at the
person with the person all that kind of
stuff right and I strove I strived one
of those two to try and mean something
this before I started doing comedy for
real I we did a performance and I just
did a bunch of impressions and I the
teacher she really liked me because I
said I'm trying to mean something with
my comedy but I'm not funny when I do
that I want to me I want my people to
walk away having learned something but
they just they want to hear they want to
see the puppet show and she liked me
because I I couldn't do it I couldn't
get it there but that's what I want to
do eventually that's 25 years ago and
then I got lost somewhere
I just lost that thing and I was just
like yeah I'm just gonna go make as much
money as I can and I was happy doing
that cuz I a lot of comedians don't have
I have a my family yeah good for you my
yeah my kids they became the first thing
watching them grow up became very
important to me my wife much less
important but still but that's all
important to me and people would say I
used to get more auditions or calls for
auditions they're like okay so this uh
this really good director wants to you
know it wasn't really the direct you
know how age this director was like it's
a it's a it's a casting person who never
even heard of I've gone into so many
auditions where hey Frank Kelly and who
I'm like I thought you guys wanted to
see me they're like we don't know start
you know what I'm talking to my agent I
always go listen and look at this part
and this doesn't seem I don't think this
is right for me do they really want to
see me you know do they or just as you
get me in here I had I had a pie in a
part that was read to read for it was a
55 year old Asian man and I was like I'm
why why am I going to well they don't
know what they want I go then why is it
written 55 year old Asian man if I try
to do that I'm done yeah you know my
pushback on what we're saying right now
is my manager said to me he said okay
yeah Eric I I know you you want to be in
stuff that they want to see you but you
know what part they didn't want to see
you it was like work
all right it happened I got you in on
that one you know he could happen it
happened he claims he claimed I got that
you're very subtle with the he call
they're bastards all of them I mean
they're trying to do the job but they're
trying to do the best thing for you and
we we stop especially me I put a stop oh
I think but I to go back to what that
point was like I would be like where
does that audition if I'd get it where
does it shoot oh that's in Iceland I'm
like I can't leave my family for two
months to go shoot in Iceland to shoot
the Avenger you just take that now look
what I'm saying I just leave the family
and the dust literally like a snap I
would go and they they would be Thanos
and I would be out there that daughter
would love me more but you weren't
really necessarily committed to being an
actor anyway though right no I wasn't
and that's that's a big problem I didn't
have a focus I wish I'd had a focus you
had a focus I did money yeah you know
really that's there's a reality that you
can you there's a show business I was
bigger in the business than the show and
even the show can be part of the
business there's the art and I wasn't
heavy on the art and there's a reality
of that and I see a lot of the people
now that we're heavy on the art the that
took them a longer time but they're
starting to do the more broad stuff but
not broad but in terms of wide ranging
in their career and I'm like I'm envious
of that I'm not just listen I'm not just
I'm not sad about anything I've done I'm
not done oh very it's all totally
content I should say I'm not content I'm
happy I'm I'm pretty happy person I'm
being driven again a little bit more to
go do something else
and it's I had the time where my kids
were smaller I spent the time that I
felt like I needed to spend with them
now they're starting to no regret in
their own no growth no regrets in that I
I miss my son early on there was I miss
my son's first steps cuz I was on the
road I'm like I can't do this I can't I
just don't want to cry I don't want to
miss these things but his first steps
we're probably in a very nice place yeah
that was actually that's the trade-off
though
well that was in that you know that was
in we were still living in LA at the
point that oh wow so here's the other
thing too it's like you come to my house
and you're like this is amazing like
this this would probably be a
two-bedroom apartment in LA yeah we are
near a zona right now Phoenix you know
so you could this guy's got a compound I
don't even want to hear him this is like
you literally have made this into a
compound it is that's what it isn't
yes wanted it to be literation yeah and
a compound
yeah yeah I always want I wanted a
drug-dealer house that's what I I really
did I want it so this is where like the
weed would be growing here oh oh you
could be where you would go flowers and
I've never done a drug in my entire life
and it I said that people don't believe
me because they're looking at me with
this at the amount of energy but and
that was only for control reasons it
wasn't I'm not a religious person I'm
not this about I'm just like I just need
i'm addictive like an addictive
personality if I started something I'm
never gonna I feel the same way I never
I never drank I don't drink alcohol I
never have and I always kind of felt
like it was because of that I felt like
ooh I think that if I start this is
gonna be too good I'm gonna keep going
because I feel that way about comedy
like I used comedy for everything man
like it's like if I'm having a trouble
like right now I'm dealing with my mom
is she's diagnosed with dementia and
I've been dealing with that and the way
I deal with it is I talk about it on
stage right you know it's just something
that I do I go to therapy but even with
that I still talk about what I want to
talk about on stage in therapy it's
crazy how it works it's funny how I've
started to do that where I start to talk
and I can see people kind of going women
have impressions come and I go this is
kind of a therapy session and then they
they start to understand a little bit of
where I'm coming from and get on board
and then they listen to me a little bit
more it's just about letting people know
it's truth you are so wrapped up in like
in like thinking that that's all that
people want yeah because you haven't
seen how it works I go up and it's like
you ever do comedy and open for a band
oh I don't you're saying yes I know what
you mean so you go I see they're just
like where's the band yeah again I'm
also the band the impressions of the
band and you can fit now that's the
older audience that's been around
forever now doing podcasts
and doing some of these even the newer
voices and just being out there on
Instagram a little bit more doing that
type of stuff is I can feel to audiences
their audience is starting to listen to
just me and then there's the old guys
going she's gonna do some John man it's
like it will be it'll be like three old
guys and then they come out to you up to
you after the show like they say things
like I liked it was good but I would
have loved if you would have done more
I've just seen a John Madden one-man
show that's what I want I want to see
four hours of John men what's the thing
he did worried yeah what's the thing he
did stuff the yard the chicken into the
duck into the turkey the turkey stick
into chicken to the turducken no that's
not it yes that's it
turducken that's what I said and that's
what in this and then I can't I get that
I mean it also became such a God such a
like an empire in a way like it became
like a you know you were like coke you
know I mean like you were like McDonald
right here's the person what you expect
you want to see and it's successful it's
fun Russians have a shelf life yeah all
right when the person is alive that's
good then they die it's just over okay
you can do it for a nostalgic person's
purposes when a president is no longer
president it's considered dated gone you
can you can throw it in there but it
can't be a staple you let's say you do
an impression of somebody that just had
a hashtag moment right there going oh a
nice ass now Liam Neeson I you trying to
at kind of voice right I don't know who
you are you know then all of a sudden
he's had some bad things that's happened
no so you get to take it from your act
right yeah Morgan Freeman had a thing he
seems to have said the crazy we can't
even be a dirty old man anymore like
that was like
like you can't happen I was like I was
struck by the almighty himself yeah that
was well yeah I was gonna say that will
get fevered from the almighty I'm not
sure what happened to that you in the
bathroom smoking crack now sing the
school song Oh nobody even knows that
reference my eyes
lean on me stand by me it's one of those
he was the HEA and I see right now they
call me the Batman what do you think
about um what do you think about this
news about Eddie Murphy trying to come
back I didn't really see it other than I
saw he was on a promo for comedians and
cars getting coffee yeah he's talking
Seinfeld's consumed about it he said I'm
gonna come back I'm gonna do it he's I
think he's gonna start coming to the
clubs I just hit up to the manager at
The Comedy Store Adam II get you know
and I was like I was like so should we
start to prepare to get bumped by Eddie
Murphy right now see we should put
should we prepare for that you know so I
think that's about to start happening
he's gonna do clubs yeah I mean that's
that's interesting I mean Robin Williams
came back and started doing but those
were huge venues that's I think that
Eddie Murphy I find him see I have
something I feel that you had the
similar thing because I think that he
had such a high level of respect for
stand-up that he didn't want to go back
to it because it was like um he was
great yeah how do you how do you how can
you ever be that again and how can you
that and how can you be see how can you
be seen on the come-up you know you
don't want to be seen in that level but
that's what it look I've seen Chris Rock
at the Comedy Store
he comes in lower your expectations s
exactly what he says yeah you know and
it's just like you go okay and he's
working it out you see him three weeks
later it's fire bah bah bah yeah so I
don't know of Eddie Murphy his just you
know we look we look at him with
reverence yeah but the young people even
know like if the young people they even
know that he was a stand-up comedian I
mean I've seen plenty of people
I'm a stand-up comedian man so yeah I
mean you know there's that's that was
part of what I've done is I started to
get away from it
I've lost a bunch of weight tried to
change a look try to do a bunch of
different things to almost be a new
person you're like a soccer coach now oh
that's always dressed like a retired guy
now just every time I see him shorts
with here's here's weird pattern shirt
what do they call this that something
stripe something but it's funny because
I have the same like I have a weird body
I like this big chest and then these
little butter knife legs you're Barney
Rubble for sure yeah and it's a weird
thing where shirts don't fit me right
they just look weird so I just buy the
same shirt in different colors totally
get this right I only shop at the big
man store you know because I'm shaped
like an ostrich
so my midsection is just so like a shirt
could be double XL so it's double XL
till it hits in my belly area and then
it expands out to triple XL so it's hard
but if I wear a triple XL it's gonna be
- I'm gonna be swimming in and up here
then but it's gonna fit down what you're
funny is it works because you're as tall
as you are
but yeah but it works no but if you were
a five foot six men I'd call you a
pear-shaped man right because then you'd
be totally a pear shape you're big so
like in terms of height so you can do
different things I think you but yeah I
wouldn't even I didn't even see it now I
like that's part of like I talked about
your walk yeah my appeal you know I mean
I know I have a weird he says I have a
weird walk it's a gate yeah I don't know
I don't I just I'm trying to work on
being healthier you know yeah actually
heared about especially because of
what's going on with my mom I said to
myself oh damn like what am I like what
cause what leads to that stuff and it's
like high blood pressure high
cholesterol that's just genetic in your
mind like no I don't dementia I know no
but I've got hardening of the arteries
is that I think it's like what do you
call the inflammation and it's all
there's things that lead to it that you
care oh really yeah you could prevent I
didn't realize that
genetically know if it would have to be
Alzheimer's man yeah if she was young if
it happened which if she was younger and
it happens and that's when you know it's
more a genetic thing from what I hear
but I've been looking into this cuz now
I'm worried about it right I mean my
mom's that's the worst hey get off get
off of WebMD yes I go destroy yourself
get a hangnail you're like WebMD then it
looks like how would hangnail leads to
AIDS you know there's always that link
you know you're just like yeah you know
six to seven degrees of Kevin Bacon yeah
dude I hate yet seven degrees of Kevin
how many degrees in sevens
six degrees 6 degrees but I think it's
separation Kevin Bacon but now that with
the internet and everything everybody's
really one away like who we're right
away from literally everybody are both
on IMDB right Instagram Twitter or
whatever it is like that right I'd even
think about that yeah you're one degree
away from your fans now that's something
you never had before and I'm trying to
get better about that because I was
always presentational and not getting
back and forth and now I try to answer
as many comments that could be a
nightmare too though well that's why I
got off of Twitter for a while Twitter
was so angry yeah that I here's part of
what I did I was one of my big speeches
that I would gain because of Monday
Night Football Night Football and doing
the Madden impression and Jon Gruden and
these other sports guys on a Sunday
night football game I could gain 2,000
followers a night essentially Oh times
up to 5,000 it's a long I went from you
know 75,000 to 300,000 in a year it was
crazy but I was just saying snarky angry
things and it started to affect me in
real life like everyday I started to
think like a snarky angry person just
looking on your thing too like who can I
write yeah who can I rip to get more
followers and is that really what I
wanted to be no but in doing that it
took me out of paying attention to a lot
of pop culture and not really knowing
what's going on so you have to be able
to filter it Instagram is a lot nicer
that's why I've gotten into that
comparative to Twitter when they would
until you go down to the comments well
I've been going on a lot like you go on
some of these motivational podcasts and
business podcasts
and then it's like Oh fantastic yeah and
they really mean it they believe it and
you you believed to and went on this
guy's add my let's podcast and it was
he's I left there going wow this guy's
energy like you know worth a fourth for
500 million dollars these richest 50
under 50 I go on there and I left
feeling like holy cow I know what this
guy's special like he's he's got that
like certain businesspeople CEOs and
stuff you walk around a bug I understand
why this person's great
I think stars had that - Tom Cruise has
that yes like that an element a glow
that that Will Smith Tom Cruise yeah
there's a thing the mega stars have you
seen them on have you seen like Will
Smith on Instagram uh-huh you got to go
to Will Smith's Instagram okay it's just
to see likes and then you can see
somebody like in your age bracket like
how they're handling Instagram right I
think he has a team of people but the
point is still he's just so dynamic or
sometimes on Instagram I don't have this
motivational thing and he'll just like
you go oh this is why this guy made it
yeah and that's part of what I'm trying
to do like I I was such a pessimist for
such a long time like that gets you
nowhere just try to try and think
positively try and think stop judging
like you know get rid of the judgment
stop being envious be happy for people
because we all do that right like
somebody gets a partner like how did
they get that and you don't think bad
for them you're just like why am I not
one of the big things I would have found
if you pay attention to yourself
you can be really happy it's as soon as
you start worrying about what everybody
else is doing you're like how do they
get that I'm just doing this and that's
all of social media yeah yeah
everybody's looking at going oh you do
out of depression yeah that's because
people are going there and a lot of
times it's not even real it's just it's
pretend people you know people look
really good but they have six filters on
yeah and they're doing all sort of she
now with this thing you can age yourself
you can make yourself younger you can
make yourself older you can you know all
the things you can do on the internet I
don't even know what people really look
like now yeah I don't know I don't know
I wanna I hate to cut you off but no I
love that nobody I just please cut me
off just show you I've been talking no
no they always tell me that yeah
that the thing they say they like about
me is I let the guests talk oh great
I think I get is that you interrupt too
much but you know what that's something
that all podcasts have you're like
you're interrupting a new chunk because
I want to ask questions I want to get I
think that oh right sometimes when they
say that them like I interrupted you and
I believe it interrupting podcast you
know no but okay
do you think that like in your height of
your career did you find yourself being
not the best person the best version of
yourself
were you like I'm a better person now a
mean guy I didn't think I was mean I
just didn't have patience I lost a lot
of patience is like I don't have time I
just so much is going on right now the
other problem is I didn't take advantage
of when I was at the height of
everything I could do I should have not
been scared and try because I had so
many extra opportunities to do other
things and I always feared what people
would say on one thing or another and I
wish I did just I wish I'd have been
doing what I'm doing now which happens
might happen and it is what it is you go
back but I what would my hadn't say
[Laughter]
control it's rude it's embarrassing at
least you got to see it happen you were
so ready to do with the ballot oh I
didn't even why I didn't want to why
right it was it was like me - it was you
were the full moon and I was changing in
the batter yeah yeah yeah it was to be a
great bit Maddon there's a world that's
not great for anybody over 75 no I'm
just saying um I lost my train of
thought don't know you cuz you were
talking about like how you wish you
would have taken chances you wish you
would have got it on your comfort zone
yeah I would love to have done that I
realized that I just wasn't trained
properly I was on TV after being on
stage from high school I went up for the
first time for real on a comedy club
stage I'd gone up once before but I
would say 1996 the graduating from
college I was on TV the first time
by 1998 oh wow was that MADtv yeah that
was on just like a late-night show Craig
Kilborn Oh got you dead then I got a
Comedy Central half-hour so I was
getting that kind of stuff within three
years oh wow and so I was hidden earned
it I didn't I didn't develop I was just
a puppet show that's the better and I
didn't know who I was I had no idea and
still are questions but the best
comedians I think have a take on like
when I want you I go geez he knows where
he's coming from you know you know where
you're gonna come from on certain things
but you know what the thing I think the
skill for this is like if you know where
you're coming from so I yes I do feel
like I know but I don't always know how
to convey that in performance that's the
hard part for me right that's but that's
that's the getting it to the stage part
you might not have that but you know
where you're coming from in the
beginning mindSHIFT
know pending and I don't always I'm
starting to get it yeah I'm starting to
get to understand you know what I
disagree with you I think that you're
starting to be okay with it
I think that that's the thing too
because I think that you're such a clean
comic you're clean it's it's a certain
type of presentation you want to be a
kids can come to your show and that's
anyone I'm trying to do it used to be
probably I would love to be able to just
let loose but there's too many people
and I'm not a huge swear but I will
swear I like in real life you'll hear me
swear but I don't do that on stage
because there's so many people right now
because there's so many people that come
out that it they're looking for
something else it's like when Bob Saget
started showing up and they look oh wow
I was crazy and he didn't but the great
thing thing was he really didn't care
right and I admire that you cared
because it's the art and you're just
trying to come from truth in who you
really are and that's who he really is
and I admire that there's always a piece
of me being hidden and that's why the
impressions are so easy for me because
it was hiding me and now trying to get a
little bit further in my own you know do
not necessarily okay with yourself yet
I'm okay with myself off and well that's
what I'm saying personally but are you
now have the talk I'm getting there but
it's just again I worry about what
people I do worry about what people are
coming to see because
I don't I don't really like to offend
people but it's turning out I'm just
starting to realize that everybody gets
offended by everything anymore so stop
worrying about it was just gonna say
that in the process of trying not to
offending anyone you actually offend
everyone you know and yourself and
you're exactly yeah I feel and I just
feel like from talking to you right now
I feel like you know you're starting to
be like no it's okay for me to think a
or B it's okay for me to think this and
say it out loud even if it's not coming
from an Impressionists impression a
voice this is what Frank Caliendo thinks
yeah and that's I mean I'm learning and
talking to other comedians which is
something I grew I came up on the
college circuit which was me all by
myself basic I was about to say you know
you skip thought the the Brotherhood you
skip the game lottery I did I yeah and I
it's because and because I wasn't a
drinker or into any drugs and stuff like
that to that I always felt awkward
around I feel awkward in high school and
dude I had friends but and then as I got
older I was I always the designated
driver because I want to and that's the
worst I kind of felt like nobody even
wanted to hang out with me they just
wanted me to drive right and then at the
end it's like I've got to put up with
these people that are just blitzed and
like each other when they're blitz but
you realize how ridiculous everybody is
when they're blitz and you're not you
know I stopped doing that I remember why
I stopped doing it cuz I thought oh man
I'm gonna be responsible like if you're
the sober guy out with a bunch of drunk
people and some stuff goes down now
you're the one they're like well you
were sober why'd you let this happen
right and I was like man not gonna be me
so I step away I stepped away after a
while I was like I'm not gonna go you
guys go have your fun that's eventually
what I did with Society and you moved
here this is Arizona Heat yeah I'm gonna
Arizona away from all this I want to be
in a kiln now man I think that it's just
I like this I like how you're
reinventing yourself I like how you're
questioning yourself I like how you're
still a little unsure and you're just
like who do me put my you putting your
toe in the water right now and to check
the temperature well there's always been
if there was one thing that I'm finding
especial
as I do look at some of the comments
because there are people that is out
there to troll you but then if you see a
certain amount of comments that are the
same and constructive huh
one thing I keep saying that people
liked from me and that's why I'm
continuing to go down that path because
it's real first of all and honest is
people like you're so vulnerable in some
of these interviews I've never seen that
from you because they always saw me as
this machine a machine yeah with the
Russians no but there's like an Isaac
MADtv I used to say hey we have to make
fun of ourselves some otherwise if we're
only making a fun of other people people
are just gonna rip us like we rip other
people you know like no that's what we
do is we just rip people I go but you
have to have a sense of humility there
if you don't have that then your fans
are all going to be the same I have a
lot of sports fans like it the the hero
strikes out at the end of the game you
know I was like oh that's okay they're
like you shook that's the same kind of
feeling yeah said that and the reaction
I get from the sports people so listen
for me it's all all learning and I being
around comics more and you know
comedians and just hearing how people
have gone through this stuff at
different points in their career usually
much earlier on but there's this it's
kind of cool that there's this I think a
little bit of respect from people when I
talk about this stuff they're like oh
man you really want it you really want
to yeah I would tell that I could tell
and it's it's it's also sad in a little
way I'm being 100 with you I'm just kind
of 95 my was gonna be like I just feel
like that I wish but that's the
vulnerability now I wish you would have
taken chances yeah oh yeah I wish no but
chances don't always buy a big pool yeah
he said he had to go turn the pool on I
was like who's turning their pool on
what do you do what's going on and isn't
seen it yeah yeah is there a water slide
on this pool there's oh my god you're a
monster for those yeah it's pretty
ridiculous probably one of the things it
was that on your bucket list of when I
get money I
again pool with a waterslide yeah well
that was because the kids oh really was
the kids
I'm the back yeah no I actually started
when I started seeing the price of it I
started taking some stuff off there were
two slides I was like whoa you were
gonna go big you're like give me two
slides and they're like well one goes
through a mountain just say no and they
have to go see this pool yeah maybe you
should go look out the back window right
now come right back no I'll just take a
picture of it okay yeah I'll take your
word for it yeah you'll be yeah you'll
see it's ridiculous yeah but you know
what that when you look at that isn't
that that I'm proud of it exactly when I
worked in Vegas listen I'm that's
another thing is it's so funny because I
remember well maybe fifteen years ago
everybody was hiding that they had stuff
nobody would show that they were on a
private jet nobody would show that a car
service was driving oh that's her those
days are done that and I missed that I
didn't know that everybody's showing
everything they have now and then
literally but I mean they're their
possession the possessions and stuff
like that I I was off of social media so
much and I started going and I feel
weird about it too because I do have a
lot I'm lucky I listen I think there's a
lot of skill that goes into things but
also there's luck I truly believe that
yeah luckiest person who's gonna be that
I mean you know who could take advantage
of the luck that's what you did you took
your sexual advantage of certain luck
I'm trying to take an advantage of other
luck but it were I mean listen I'm not
regrets no no I mean there are some
regrets but also on the other side of it
very happy about yeah great but there is
there is that element of sadness of when
you listen to what some of the simple
I'm trying to fix that inside of me now
it's a fire it's something it's actually
something good and this is why because
that there's a fire that's burning in me
to become better again where I'd lost
that for a while with the complacency I
was stuck there and it's funny because
people listen to me on some of these
like and maybe they listening in your
podcasts they won't think but they'll
say geez that's kind of motivation like
I've got people that want like
corporations and stuff now I like come
talk to our company and don't just do
your stand-up actually tell us about
your story and that's
the next step to me is who are you what
do you come frequently actually becoming
interested and I always fought the
vulnerability angle I didn't want people
to see that I was vulnerable and that's
because you're Italian that's a big part
of you so you don't be weak even though
you live with your mom - you were 40 you
know that's not Italians you know but
it's part of the learning you know again
looking back it's really easy to to say
I should have done this - no but by the
way by the way it's great to look back
yeah it's great to look back from a
position of from the time of your pool
right yes from the second your second
house on your compound yeah and your
pool you have to turn on yes it's easy
to look back and be like ah you know I
probably could have done this so I
admire that you're in that position and
at the same time I also admire it
because you're in that position and
you're going okay
I still want to do this part of it that
I never did and I wish that I did yeah
and that's the fight I mean that's
that's the great thing about right now
is I was talking about somebody who does
branding and like Instagram and all that
kind of stuff and they're like you know
what's amazing about you I'm like what
they're like you get to be a new person
on Instagram you don't have to be the
same person you were and like exactly
you get it new right there's new people
that I can there's actually people that
don't even know you do impressions right
yeah now you're just the guy that's been
on podcasts right that's a weird there's
a piece of that yeah and they're like oh
he also does some pretty good
impressions and I'm like what pretty
like this is something that everybody
deals with man because when I was a
comic for a while then I got on
workaholics and then as I was on
workaholics people didn't know I was a
comic right they just thought I was just
a weird comedic actor you know to me
yeah and I listen III admire you I think
that's you have like I said you have the
dramatic you have
the comedic both the acting you've got
stand up yeah but none of that led to a
custom pool partially cuz you ever been
to a billionaires house oh right right
si don't you saying I mean have you ever
been to a billion I just recently was
the first time I've ever been to a
billionaires you thought and I'm not
doing enough I was like I
when you say custom like yeah okay so I
get to pick how the tiles went the [ __ ]
you know the pattern they're gonna be
put in they have their name in the grout
right it's it's a different level but
the colors are Taiwanese boys flown in
to do the work you know to me I love
right now I love right now is like this
is one of these moments right another
you're like I don't know if I want to
jump in on I don't know if my crowd
wants me to jump I'm gonna say no
they're paying full price like oh and
it's gonna come across as a certain way
it was brutal but you're gonna take a
chance everyone so I mean it's just me
and put it out there Caliendo yeah
Caliendo huh it's Kelly that's that I
would get that too like this was funny
early on because people come out to see
me and like they beat Latino yeah and
they're disappointed you know what we
know my uh my my best moment for
disappointing someone when they saw that
it was me and didn't want it to be me is
I'm getting off a plane it's late you
know I'm going I'm a club I'm there the
night before this press in the morning
the guys got to the phone if they're the
thing it says II Griffin you know and
when I walked up to him he goes man you
wait Eddie Griffin
you ain't Eddie Griffin oh just like he
what I did and then he just like come on
man you know I'm like okay you know we
gets in the car the whole car ride from
the airport to the hotel he's on me a
tow everybody get up Eddie Griffin
you ain't Eddie Griffin they asked Oh
Eddie Griffin you know two years ago it
and I was like okay dude great like the
most unprofessional but you know
what I felt for him you know because he
legitimately wanted it you know so I
didn't want to like all his manager and
be like hey this guy was really
unprofessional I just let it go but I
was like man I really disappointed I
could you imagine if you're a different
type of person like I it was funnies
recently a manager to club was calling a
radio station and he said yeah I got he
looked at me couldn't remember a name
he's like John Caliendo I know what that
is it's him thing man and he gets off
the phone he's like hey I'm sorry but
then I get to the radio station and they
they it's really funny because then they
have a one-sheet which is like an
information yeah
and so they have my in my bio on there
and it's Craig shoemakers name and bio
on there it's like so - like the club
and the manager both and I'm sorry Craig
shoemaker does this thing the
love-master so I started like I'm
derivative I'm doing a tribute act on
the sock monster burger so it's just
like I make fun of it cuz I don't care
but you imagine being somebody that is
up there hey there's people do they care
yeah and that's two things in the same
day so you're like wow this club doesn't
really care about me but I hate going to
radio and then the radio guy just reads
your bio
I owe ya the questions are like so Frank
III here in 1996 you did this you know
it's nobody like that and nobody talks
throw the stuff out there it's so
obvious they really don't know about you
don't care they get the facts wrong on
it you know what I like to do I like to
interview them at that point I say man
what are you just gonna read my bio
are you married let's find out about you
right now and then you get uncomfortable
they're like oh you know okay then we
start talking about that that's what I
like to do I can't stand that yeah I
just I just agree with you're so scared
scaredy-cat scaredy-cat Kelly about
dirty cat scaredy Kelly and you know how
to end them you know what this is this
is good I'm coming back to Arizona again
another time and every time I come we'll
just continue our conference I feel like
we've talked for a long time I feel like
I could talk to you forever I'm listen
I'm so glad you know between the same
agent go ahead yeah we do yeah
yeah yeah yeah cuz my guy Ryan has one
to hit me up like listen man you know
Frank Kelly I was gonna be in town and
then if for some reason you weren't in
town and you changed it I was I was
thinking about coming to LA and then my
daughter has some that her arm issue
that I don't know so she's got two
doctors coming this week no regrets so
well an elbow that isn't healing after a
year so we've got some specialists and
stuff like that there's no disease in
the bone or anything like that it's just
she's a stubborn healer and we can't
figure out what it is exactly so that
was a big big deal and that's what's
happening in this next week so I'm not
going back to LA then I saw that you
were coming here I'm like let's just do
that that's perfect yes this worked out
great and then I was on his podcast so
make sure you go to Frank Caliendo what
it would have Alan Frank tried to be
serious you can go to Alan Frank calm or
you can go at Alan Frank on the IG at
Frank Caliendo
across the board on everything on
different social media if you can't
spell Caliendo it's the letter c the
word alien and the word do so at Oh
Frank C alien do C alien do comedy but
you've never done that before huh you
know I really love the Eric Griffith
Show
let me tell you the joke I get all the
time hey man do the glasses nose and
mustache come off
that's the joke I get all the time it's
so original I and that's why exactly why
I wouldn't say it but there is a real
Frank Caliendo Ferno but they're never
coming back for me enough being on the
podcast and that's not just being on the
podcast but being a gracious host in his
podcast studio as you can see it looks
different from riffing with Griffin but
this is a special on the road episode
and I really appreciate you having me
here thanks for coming in and I looking
forward to seeing your journey and where
it's gonna lead to I know that's gonna
lead to a probably a fantastic
vulnerable special of just there's a
real I would like that yeah just called
Frank you know what I mean you know
doing it your way right
not as old blue eyes that when I was in
Vegas they were trying to figure out a
way to do Frank's back and because
they're like I'm like no no no no oh god
people coming he he's not doing Sinatra
I'm more worried if I'm more worried
about the Italian side he's done Yeah
right right right just tell your mob
still the thing cut s it up for him
that's like oh we not a thing what a
thing you know who's this every day that
story about Uncle Phil something next
time you can't get cheese in Chicago
we're not going to me what do you mean I
can't get cheese in Chicago no guys oh
you know under steam I gotta give one of
those guys that has a guy for everything
oh yeah I got a q-tip guy I got a I got
a guy for a q-tip - I got a generic
patent swab guy can't afford the q-tips
and it gets your deal I got a guy who
gets guys all right anyways we look at
this we'll just keep going this is Eric
Griffin this is Frank Caliendo this is
riffing with Griffin and thanks for
listenin I see you guys next week
absolutely fabulous
[Music]